hey hello friends welcome back and
friends in today's session also we are
going to discuss another 10 uh Linux
networking command and at the same time
we came to the end of this Linux
networking uh uh commands guys so this
will be the last episode or you can say
the last part of this Linux 50 plus uh
networking command I hope you have liked
the series uh and there is also one
reason that why I have I did this series
my friend because AWS series is going to
start soon and for that you need to
understand few networking command at the
same time you need to understand the
networking Concepts also okay so this is
why this series is very helpful for you
and uh hopefully you have liked the
series and if you have liked the series
then please don't forget to like share
and subscribe the channel and press the
Bell icon for the latest notification my
friends so let's start with the command
number 42 my friend so the command
number 4 2 is SSH command and suppose uh
you want to do SSH from one Linux server
to the other Linux server in the
previous uh session only in this series
only I have explained you how to create
a uh SSH key that I have already
explained you but in this series I'm
going to show you okay if you have
deployed already with one of the Linux
machine how you can deploy the same
public key to the other Linux machine so
uh what what is written here is like SSH
we are trying to SSH to a different IP
uh from the main server okay and uh it
means that securely log to the Linux
server or machine okay so let me show
you how we can do this one my friend
okay so you can see uh what is the IP of
This Server so you can see clearly the
IP of this server is uh 214 right and
what is the IP of This Server uh let's
first clear it out okay if have config
right so IP of this server is 212 so
what I'm going to do is rightly I'm
going to do SSH to this server but if
you remember in the previous session of
this series only I have explained that
uh if you're logging to the other server
right so you need to deploy the public
key let's see I have not deployed the
public key what error we are going to
get over here so just enter this
one so because the public key we have
created the SSS authentication key we
have created with password list but here
it's asking you the password okay let me
put the
password right and you can see I'm able
to login so if you if I do who am I so I
am the root user but if I do if config
so you can see the IP is changed but
it's asking me the password so
to login password list because you are
in the same network so what we need to
do my friend so first thing is let's go
to this directory so you'll understand
you'll remember everything okay so if
I'll do LL if you guys remember properly
this is the private key and this is the
public key right and the public key I
have deployed if you remember 192
16872 do 211 server and this is 212
server right so in this case again we
need to deploy this public key from I
have just named This Server as ncble
controller and from ncble controller we
can log to multiple SSH uh client that
is as different Linux server so here I'm
trying to log to This Server
passwordless my friend that is
212 so how I can achieve this one my
friend let me show you okay so you see
uh so you see now this public key has to
copy to This Server right so so how we
are going to do this
one so so friends I am going to use this
command if you remember properly in the
previous session only okay so I am going
to run this command and instead of 211 I
have given 212 and as soon as you do
enter so it's now going to ask you the
password first time
okay
Enter now you can see clearly it's added
the public key my friend okay
now what we need to do is run the same
command you will see okay SSH enter see
now you are able to log to the other
server which is which is which server my
friend
okay that is 212 correct if I do if
config over here so you can see I'm able
to log to 212 with a passwordless this
is why we deploy the public key to all
of the Linux server wherever you want to
log in from this sensible controller to
the all Linux servers my friend and in
This Server your private key will be
there
okay so friends let's move on to the
next command and the next command is
ncat command or NC command uh normally
we call it as a nit cat command also but
nit cat command is I'm it's not going to
support by rhl L so ncat command is
there and N command and cat command is
uh basically used for the utility for
reading from and writing to the network
connection my friend so here let's
execute this command uh there won't be
any output for this one let's see uh
what output we're going to get over here
okay so uh let me show you first uh
let's first see which server we are so
we are still on 212 so I'm going to exit
from here so now we are into which
server we are into back to the ncble
controller server if you want to see you
can see right it's 214 correct so let me
clear it out and I'm going to run the
command called anet hun you can run NC
also and zv my friend okay and
192 168 do
72. 2
214 my friend so here you can see the
connection is refused okay so you are
going to get the error like this and if
you if you try to do the other server
also what output we are going to get no
route to host my friend okay just try to
understand what anet command does over
here is that's absolutely fine because
we have connected with virtual machine
so we are getting this output my friend
okay so if I do man and Cat right right
and cat so you can come to know it's
concatenate and redirect sockets my
friend right so and ncat is a feature of
network utility which reads and writes
the data across network from the command
line my friend okay you can use multiple
output with this one so this I have left
it with you only so just try it out
different option with the anat command
and NC command both are same only okay
so let me clear this out and let's move
to the next command my friend so the
next command is aring command you have
seen in this series only in the previous
command I have shown you how to SCP but
there is something called aring okay so
there is a very basic difference between
s SCP command and ring okay so this
question could be asked to you in
interview also okay so there is already
I have explained this one in Linux 100
plus interview question and answer you
can go and you can understand that what
is the difference between SCP and RC
okay so here I'm going to because in the
previous command in this series only I
have shown you uh SCP command but now
I'm going to show you how we can use Arn
command both are same only basic
difference is Arn will see wherever the
copy will stop this also copy this
command will also copy your one file to
the one server to the other server means
from the suppose you uh from if I'll
talk about from this Linux machine to
this Linux machine but in case of our
sync where if suppose some because of
some reason there is some Network glitch
will be happened so the network
connection timed out or the network
connection disconnected so in that case
you don't need to copy from scratch from
zero so wherever it lives it starts from
there only my friend this is the basic
difference between SCP and R sync
okay so it's like suppose you are doing
a 400 m okay just try to understand
stand okay you are doing a 400 m and uh
you have already run uh first 100 m okay
so in case of SCP suppose you have uh if
you have to reach 400 m if you have to
complete Source from the destination and
you have completed 200 M and in some
because of some reason you have to
the race then again you need to start
from where you have started means from
again from zero but in case of our sying
suppose you have already completed the
200 M so if you Abed also okay the race
so you can start from 200 only and you
need to complete the next 200 to reach
to the destination this is just a normal
example I have explained to you okay so
let me try how it works my friend okay
so here let's see what all files are
there so here you can see uh Earth
original there is one file okay and this
uh data if you can see is there any data
inside this one yes so there is a data
inside this one one and this data
friends I have copied from my own
website so if anyone is willing to buy
any of these t-shirts which I wear on a
regular basis so you this is my own
website as I told you uh I have only
hosted this website completely and this
brand Belongs to Me Only my friend Earth
original so this is so you can see all
all you can in the description you can
get all these details and if you want to
buy you can go ahead and buy these
t-shirts or good quality t-shirts and at
a reasonable price rest all up to you
okay coming back to the point my friend
so here what I have done
is uh so I have given this one so now
let's see uh let me clear this out okay
so I am going to do R sync okay and what
I'm going to do over here is I'm going
to copy this one which file Earth
original right and where I want to copy
root at the rate
of 192 okay
168 72. 212 okay and where you want to
copy you want to copy at the root
directory only so it's copied now you
can go here okay and you can check also
okay in the cd/ if you do and if you see
here it's already copied correct in 212
correct if you want to see the data also
it's as it is correct so this is how we
can use RC command and sap command my
friend okay so let's move on to the next
command my friend that is nmtui command
and nmtui command is used to text user
interface for controlling network
manager let's see so if you run
NM Tui correct enter so are you able to
see like this so you are going to get
what this is a network manager that is
what I it's clearly text user interface
for controlling network manager so you
can edit any of these my friend okay so
whether if suppose you want to edit any
of this connection that is ens 33 so you
can edit this one my friend okay so uh
it's totally up to you how you're going
to do this one so let's come back from
here okay so if you want to add an
additional interface you can add it you
can add with the this nmtui command my
friend okay and let's
quit Okay so same command okay so I have
run that command in This Server uh in
the other server uh you can run the same
command you can see in this rhl both are
uh you can see this is rhl 7 and this is
rhl 9 okay so both the version you have
so let me run the same command over here
nmtui correct you can get the same UI
here also there is no difference okay so
this also gives an gives an idea to you
if you I do cad/ ATC if I do red hat
release so you can see here right this
is
9.3 and if I want to do cat / Etc okay
Red Hat release so you can see sento is
also a red hat drro only but the name is
just change it uses the same core rhl
core only okay and it's a open source
more it's a open uh Source operating
system okay so this is almost 7.9 or 7
and this is uh your n see in both I have
shown you the command it's working same
only there is no much
difference okay so let's move on to the
next command my friend this command
might will not work in this system
because it not supports but to show you
uh if if it supports in some of the uh
because of the internet okay so etth
tool hyph s etth z speed 100 duplex full
uh let me show you the command let me
clear this out and first let me take the
interface name this is the interface
name my friend okay and let me clear
this one and etth Tool correct etth tool
hyphen s okay and you can see uh I need
to give the interface name and then
speed correct
and
duplex and full so you can see as I told
you before only it's going to give you
operation not permitted uh operation not
supported right so it's absolutely fine
but this command is genuine command you
can use it for what for to change the
speed of a dup setting of an Ethernet
device so the next command is SSL sorry
SS hyphen L command is there to show the
listening sockets you have seen few
examples I have shown you also in this
in this series only so hyphen L
different options you can use with SS
command and if you want to know what all
options you can use just do a man it's
another utility to investigate your
socket so you can use n number of
command L is listening display you can
see here it's clearly mentioned display
or listening sockets right so whatever
the sockets it's there it's going to
show you SL SS hyphen L see it's showing
you so let me do a less so you'll get a
clear picture right so whatever the
sockets are there it's going to show you
correct whichever it's listening it's
going to show you my friend okay let's Q
quit and just clear this one and friend
let's move on to the next command the
next
command you will get an idea you have
seen you should ask a question abishek
you have used dig command you have used
NS lookup command now you are using host
command okay now you will understand
what is the difference between di
command host command and NS lookup
command all are DNS lookup utility on
but there is a slight slight differences
are there in all these commands so if
somebody is going to ask you in the
interview so please don't get confused
with these commands my friend okay so I
going to run the command called host
command and
google.com so you can see it's giving me
a output that the address of Google is
this plus it's giving me this Google
Mail is handled by which SMTP server
they have their own SMTP server If
instead of this one if I do my own
website okay let me do it okay
Earth
origal correct so you can see it's
managed by as I told you hostinger right
right correct so it's going to give you
the SMTP server name also uh which is
mentioned over here but in case of if I
run a DI command okay same thing if I
run a DI command for this Google Dot my
friend so what I output I'm going to get
a complete description of your forward
slash backward slash right a complete
description of your forward lookup zone
or reverse lookup Zone like that you are
going to get your name server details
right and friend if you run the command
NS look up correct
and
google.com correct so you can see
clearly you are going to it's resolving
the IP to host and host to IP correct so
this is the basic difference between
your uh host command and uh NS lookup
command and dig command now you have
understand
right so let's move on to the next
command my friend and this command
please remember because in rcss
certification also this command you have
to use it okay so if somebody is going
to ask you okay uh what is the
difference between NM CLI device so and
NM CLI connection so so you will tell no
both are same no my friend see if you
understand both are going to show you
about your network interface only but
there is a slight difference between see
every command if every command would be
same how come they have created the
another command there should be some
differences right so this is the reason
that they have created the command NM
CLI is common okay but device so and
connection so is different okay how it
is different you will understand NM CLI
device so to get the complete
information about your known devices let
me run this command then you'll better
understand my friend let me clear this
out and NM CLI right and what we have to
run over here is device and so correct
so you can see what we are getting over
here we are getting
a we are getting a what to complete
information about known devices of your
complete information of your known
devices my friend are you understanding
my point
correct so let's uh let's quit this one
okay and here only what I'm going to do
is I'm going to run the another command
nmcli connection
so connection so see now you see the
difference between these two commands so
the other command this is what the next
command is so I have mentioned slash
device and slash connection so so NM CLI
connection so to get an overview of an
active connection profiles so this is
your uu ID right this is your uu ID
which we also use where which we also
use Etc where if you want to see this
one so you'll get an idea my friend
where we use this command SL
Etc FS tab here you see so there is a
swap partition which is mounted not
using by any partition Name by using
this uu ID this is a depth of
information I'm giving you to
troubleshoot in Suppose there are some
issues so in that case if you can remove
this also okay so this this is very very
important so please don't delete this uu
ID by mistake you don't think this is
some kind of a no no no no no no this is
what this is this is your active
connection
profiles correct what is your active
connection over here so your active
connection is this interface that is ens
160 and for this one The UU ID is
this you guys are understanding my point
so friends uh this is all about in this
Linux 50 plus networking command I hope
you have liked the series and friend I'm
ending up the session here only thank
you for watching this video for more
videos like this please don't forget to
like share and subscribe the channel and
press the Bell icon for the latest
notification my friend please do
subscribe to this channel more and more
so that we can grow this together please
do take care of your loved ones till
then my friend Jin and bye-bye